i've i you know and it's it's it's a lot
of tribalism
yeah i think one of the reasons you
mentioned earlier like you have friends
who are scared that if they vote for
trump they'll no longer be seen as
liberal
yeah and i think it's because their
tribal tribalism is survival it's a
it's a survival mechanism so if you've
got people who
don't have the the independence the
self-esteem to live on their own
they're very likely going to just do
whatever the tribe says
and just many of them will believe it
because it's the safe bet
just to go with the flow and hope the
collective protects you
yeah you got a bunch of people it's no
surprise
that it's you know conservatives
individualists personal responsibility
who challenge that narrative i think
what's happening now is
the unifying force between what brings
liberals over to conservatives is the
true liberals
like actual the actual word liberal
classical liberalism
not you know this whatever mainstream is
it's individualism it's it's
the right of free expression freedom of
speech individual rights
liberty individualism is the antidote to
collectivism
whether that collectivism is racism or
sexism and that's
that's the only thing that's ever pushed
it back and now we're
moving away from that in the knee and
and they're saying it's for this good
cause and
and they used to not openly so they used
to hide the fact that they were
opposed to individualism but the
ideology is in a new phase now in the
past two months or so
it's really ramped up and i'm sure
you've see it's all the major
corporations are speaking it you know
mcdonald's is telling me about
right honestly just give me a
cheeseburger
they're all speaking it it's in churches
it's in hobby groups
it's in your kid's school there there's
a book called anti-racism baby
it's babies um but it's everywhere now
and it's uh oh man i'm losing my train
of thought
about it moving about it ramping up what
were you saying right before that i
don't remember
you got me laughing i got you laughing
i'm sorry it's yeah
it's anti-racism baby in schools did you
see the leaked curriculum
from this oh i've seen so much lee
curriculum in the past few years tell me
which one
it's it's this particular math problem
i've mentioned probably several times
now but
where we used to do math problems that
were like you know if
a farmer has you know 17 000 apples and
his warehouse can hold thirteen thousand
what percentage will rot
there was a math problem it was like if
the police you know stop and detain
you know ten thousand and two white
people but three thousand four hundred
black people what percentage of black
people are being detained by the police
right and it's like what are you putting
in this math problem that's nothing to
do with teaching kids math we do apples
they're slipping that in yes it's
through the side so the actual problem
is you know just a regular math problem
but they
they they're seeding all the stuff and
it is it is
it's creepy so yeah go ahead well as we
say
part of what's happened in the past two
months is is also that
and i was talking about this with with
you earlier lydia or maybe with tiffany
but so there used to be on social media
there was this
group of people who they weren't social
justice evangelists like i was they
weren't
actively preaching it but they had sort
of casually accepted a lot of the tenets
of the ideology
yeah and those people really didn't
preach it or push it or anything and
a lot of them for example were the kind
of women who would do just like a lot of
selfies or
look how great my family life is i have
the perfect family look at all my kids
my life's awesome keeping up with the
joneses on social media right yeah
a lot of those basic normies
are now have been activated and i don't
know if you've noticed been the ta
past two months a lot of those people
who used to post just selfies and look
at my great life are
suddenly posting constant social justice
stuff yep
and it's almost like sleeper cells they
got turned on
i think of it that way yeah they have
tacitly accepted some of the
premises of the belief system they had
soaked it up by osmosis and then
in the past two months the belief system
said okay
now you're gonna prove that you're in
this this cult that is really
interesting because
i know that you are coming from a like a
leftward position
i'm seeing the exact opposite with some
of my facebook friends like i haven't
really
really
yeah i have a few lady friends who i've
known for
multiple years i used to work with them
and they are turning more and more
conservative and i was like
i never would have expected this from
like my crystal collecting hippie friend
oh wow yeah my crystal collecting hippie
friends are turning conservative and i'm
like
what is going on here people are being
more and more upfront with their
politics
so i don't know what's happening or if
it's good or bad i think that's a
response to what i was talking about
which is now it's become so dominant
maybe you've got this reaction starting
to happen
people are waking up or people like i
said are leaving the left because it's
become
it's become almost too much have you are
you familiar with uh ryan long
the comedian yes i saw his really funny
he's got the super viral
woken racist guys yes and they get along
on everything
he has another one where it's left and
right and they're trying to pick
basketball teams
oh i haven't seen that one it's so good
it's another really good one the
the left left-wing guy is just
constantly yelling and insulting and
he's like
he's like what are you doing he's like
you you're a racist you're i'm going to
take a picture i'm taking your picture
and then the one guy goes my boss just
called me
i got fired and then the dude the dude
on the right goes
just play with me man i don't care and
they're like i'm gonna go play with this
guy
the dude walks over and the guy with the
right wing shirt goes hey you see that
trump video is pretty pretty reasonable
right it's like yeah whatever i don't
care
but so like the left is just so it's
become so angry
and bombastic that it's pushing people
away yeah
of all types do you see that that famous
marion williamson video
she's the hippie crystal woo lady yeah
and i mean look she's not really the
crystal woo-woo lady
that's what they called her she's so
nice she's so nice and that was me
so i mean for one thing the media just
relentlessly tore her apart
as the crystal woo lady yeah and she's
like i don't own any crystals that's
crazy poor lady and then she was on fox
and it was kind of a hot mic moment
where she was just shocked like why are
the conservatives so nice to me
and the left is so mean yeah i remember
that and then she kind of got mad
because they were like they published it
well it's true and i mean we'll look at
brett weinstein for example
the evergreen college fiasco he went on
fox news
which they took as even further evidence
of his
evil but yeah because fox news is the
only legacy media that would talk to him
because
the the rest of the legacy medias
they've got their one narrative they're
going to push
and if if what you know if your story
doesn't fit it they're not going to
cover it
but they can't let you go they can't how
crazy is it you know i grew up with fox
news being fake news
and yummy too and today fox news is like
they're accurately reporting on what's
going on they're biased they are biased
but it's to their benefit to
you know i mean they've been kind of
negative on trump in certain
circumstances that made him angry
they they brought in bernie sanders for
a town hall they hired donna brazile
unlike fox news is trying to capture the
moderates and the liberals man yeah
and guess what it's working if i have to
watch
legacy media now i guess i'll pick them
and it used to be the uh i mean i used
to i was
i used to put them on in the gym just so
i get angry and run faster on the
treadmill
you know that's brilliant i love it you
know i remember
you know bill o'reilly's son goes up son
comes down you can't explain that you
remember that
famous i don't remember that bit no he
was i can't remember who he was
interviewing but he was like you know
there are things we can't explain type
goes in todd goes out you can't explain
this
sun goes up sun comes down and the dude
there was like
are you are you joking we explained this
500 years ago
a little behind but but so you know i
can drag fox news where they used to be
but i think tucker carlson is now he's
the best guy in cable he's the best guy
in cable tv i
absolutely agree and and gives the
straight i mean
obviously still biased we're all biased
in some way but
at least he gives uh i think a take that
matches up with reality more than the
rest
the rest is the rest is living in that
1984
version of whatever is rewritten today
is now fact and they're believing it and
and he's he's not generally he's not
doing that
and i don't know get over you're
embarrassed i had to get over my
embarrassment of saying that i like
tucker carlson now
i i was in portland and this is a crazy
thing
a couple years ago i was in portland
there was a right wing event there's a
lefting event i actually had some antifa
see me and i was like oh here it goes
and it was some young women and
they walked up and this one woman goes i
think you're really awesome you know but
i gotta keep it quiet because people
might get mad i said that
this was like a year and a half ago or
two two years ago i think when i was in
portland maybe three actually it's been
a long time
but uh like this is at a time when i was
covering and interviewing right-wing
people
and the left was attacking me for it and
there was a couple people in portland
who were overtly in black block saying
like yo keep it up man just you know
i can't let people i'm not gonna
high-five you because people are gonna
yeah
so i don't know what the deal was with
these people but
i was in portland there was a ton of
people i i was at a bar
and this guy walks over and gave me a
bottle of hot sauce and i was like what
is this and he goes you're timpool right
i was like yeah he goes hey man good job
you could have this it's on the house
and it was really good
and there were people in portland who
were straight up like i know what you do
you do a great job
like we need we need this and i was
critical of antifa on blacklight the
entire time
wow but i bring the story up because i
was standing on a street corner and one
of these lefties was talking to me
saying like what do you think about the
fake news and all the stuff and i
mentioned i think there carlson's
actually
actually does a good job you know i
think you know a lot i i i do like
anderson cooper a little bit but
you know he's certainly gone off the
deep end in a lot of ways i used to be a
bigger fan
and i think her carlson does a pretty
good job somebody filmed it
some lefty filmed it and then like tried
making it a scandal
tim likes tucker carlson did they turn
into a song
no no they were just trying to nobody
cares nobody nobody cares they like
it it's it's temples and milk toast
fancy nobody nobody the hit pieces on me
are like
you know they don't they don't stick
because i'm too boring you know
it's true so they they try and it's like
that dude he's like
milk toast fence sitter what does that
mean that you're not they think they
they want you to pick a political party
well so uh
i don't know who coined this it was a
comment on a video a long time ago
they said tim poole is a milk toast
fence sitter and
milk toast is a reference to this old
comic right i know what milk toast means
but
right but what do they say what are they
like i won't i won't join anything
sitting on parties or candidates
everything okay
yeah because i'd be like well look the
democrats are at least saying this
and the republicans are saying this to
be completely honest i don't think it's
fair
to say i'm a militant sitter like
literally i think it's a funny joke
yeah but i've straight up was like i'm
gonna vote for trump because the
democrats have gone completely insane
pending some changes oh yeah me too like
i'm interested in
people ask me what about unity2020 you
said you kind of like that and i do
yeah and if something materializes with
that and there's a viable candidate
who's a liberal that i like i would
consider that still
but as of today i think i'm probably
voting for trump yeah look
trump tried to pull our troops out of
afghanistan that to me was like
he could have he could have handed me a
hundred 100 bill you know what i mean
i love that he did that he's he's
talking about pardoning
some people we'll see if he actually
pulls it off these are these are these
are little you know
it's it's whispering sweet nothings
we'll see if actually does anything
but i think he's improved i think the
war thing is really really big
and with the riots going on no one no
the democrats calling them peaceful
protests and lying the media lying about
it
i tell you man i read articles on this
every morning i wake up for 81 days like
here's the
morning update on the riots because they
happen every night and
these websites just say protester
protester demonstrator
and it's the funniest sentence when it's
something like you know a cop was
bludgeoned
to you know to a concussion by a by
demonstrator i'm like no no
no no no that's like they they they
barricaded the exits to the police
department and tried to burn it down
yeah demonstrators tried to burn down a
police department with human beings
inside
so anyway my point is um you know the
unity 2020 thing i think is interesting
but i no i i'm not confident
look if it's it's possible they plot a
candidate who's got a bunch of good
things behind them
they don't have a lot of time yeah and i
don't think they're going to win
and i'll tell you what man if trump is
he's literally trying to withdraw from
afghanistan
that's not that's not a promise he's
literally trying to do it yeah i'm like
all right i'll take it
i'll take what i can get you know that's
that's that that was a big deal for me
with obama it struck me emotionally and
now trump literally did it so i'm like
that's the best i can do i don't care
about your tribe i don't care about
getting canceled i don't care what you
think about the orange man
i care about bringing the remainder of
our troops out of these the middle
eastern countries and
and sealing this bit of history off and
it's and it's a blight on
on the past 20 years for this country
well what you just described
is what we talked about earlier having
principles that
are up here above party or tribe or
ideology
so it's like if i believe in peace and i
want less war
well i'm going to pick the candidate
that looks like they're leading us
towards
less war or if i believe in free speech
i've got to go with the candidate that
supports free speech and
it doesn't matter if they're in your
party or not
you know get over that that your
identity is linked to whatever your
political beliefs are that's stupid
if if if it was bernie sanders doing the
same thing i'd be like i'll take what i
can get
you know i voted for tulsi in the
primaries you know
if if she were running i might i
probably wouldn't be voting for trump
i'd probably be voting for her
yeah i supported tulsi specifically
because of her stance on war
but also her willingness to reach reach
across the aisle try and communicate
with trump supporters and conservatives
she was fairly progressive and there was
there was a lot of things i didn't
like about her campaign i mean she was
opposed she's opposed to nuclear energy
uh fairly progressive but more in line
with
you know i've gone through a lot of her
policies and i was like i'll the war
thing right off the bat
i was like that's kind of what i want
everything else i'm kind of like yeah i
don't like that don't like that but
that's okay
and i think she was willing to
compromise by having real conversations
that to me was important that's yeah
and she wasn't making and she did not
speak woke totally
and the bombs she dropped on kamala
harris i was like everybody was that was
a war crime man
yeah yeah that was seriously the only
war crime she'll ever okay
a violation of one of those conventions
whatever but geneva i was so happy
great so happy i love that uh and you
know when she supported impeachment i
was really let down
yeah that was such a fake stupid what
was the
you know i don't know man but i can
respect that
uh she ended up what would she do she
she abstained i guess
in the end i can't remember it's been a
while remember i think she did
yeah i can i can respect her efforts you
know to me
i may not agree with her with a lot of
her policies but i thought it was really
important to support people like yang
and tulsi because they were trying
to have some kind of unity and so while
i could say this
if we had a politician who was
i don't know probably out there on some
policy ideas on the left
but their whole you know campaign was
like working with trump and trump
supporters to bring america together
america together i'd happily support
that you know we we've got
this insane division in this country
and we can easily have conversations
with anybody
but the left is just unwilling for the
most part
they'll have debates they always love to
say like i'll challenge you to a debate
and there there are some people on the
left that i absolutely respect a lot
there's a lot there's a lot of people on
the left who are willing to have real
conversations
they're not the old like the super super
woke fairly progressive however
but there's too many on the left that
and and probably a lot of these like you
know sleeper cell type people you've
mentioned
it's impossible to get through and have
conversations with yeah well they don't
want to
so one of the things i started doing
after the election was i started these
things called civility dinners
and i started doing these in austin
texas and we would get together people
on the left and the right
so we had trump voters clinton voters
third party writers not whatever
everyone came different religions
atheists and then we just have dinner
and talk
and when people ask me about them
they're like well how do you
handle you know when people get really
angry at each other
but the thing is they self-select for
for people who are hungry to discuss
things again
with those who disagree with them so we
don't get ideologues we don't get social
justice warriors which are
the ideologues on the left and we don't
get white nationalists or any ideologues
from the right
we get people who want to talk with
other people who disagree i don't even
you know the left and the right thing in
this country
just makes no sense you know it's not
important anymore
not right now i don't think it is well i
just mean in terms of like far left and
far right
oh okay i always struggle with this to
try and describe because white
nationalists aren't
necessarily far right by by like not
economically at least
they're not laissez faire capitalists
they're not anarcho-capitalists aren't
libertarians
they're not going to be voting for ron
paul you know to get on the gold
standard well hitler is a socialist in
that economically right
so that's a really interesting debate
you know that they like
i know that's a debate but he did he did
talk about it
so i get my understanding that i've
pieced together and i'm not going to
pretend to be a historian any of this
stuff
was that it was kind of like for his
select group of people socialism
right you know and so it was like
ethno-socialism or something
he you know they like to say he's far
right authoritarian
what i've tried what i've kind of pieced
together is that there's two different
lefts and rights as we talk about it
there's cultural and economic and so on
so this is the problem with the right
there's actually not necessarily a real
far right
and you can you can actually go to the
eight the anti-defamation league's
website and c
they have multiple categories for what
they constitute far right it makes no
sense
anti-government far right you know uh
white supremacists far right
you know uh sovereignty isn't far right
super government far right yeah exactly
exactly exactly
and like they they label a guy far left
who was an ethno-supremacist
but he was a black identity extremist so
he had the same ideology as a white
nationalist but his skin color
determined left wing
that's not fair to the left you know
what i mean like so
what i end up seeing is you you have a
left in this country the far left are
both economic and culturally far left
in the sense that they're ultra
progressive erase the traditions tear
down the founding fathers
and also communism right but then on in
terms of the far right
we don't have a very powerful and active
mainstream anarcho-capitalist base we
don't have a very powerful and prominent
libertarian
you know base the libertarian party is
the third biggest party so
they're fairly large but they're not
nearly as powerful as the woke people
are with all the major corporations on
their side
and we have a very microscopic ultra
traditionalist
right which you know may overlap with
some white nationalists or many of them
probably
but they're you know particularly
irrelevant
here's what scares me though is you know
this
for ev for every action there's an equal
and opposite reaction right this whole
this law that exists so i am afraid
that the social justice left which is
the biggest threat i think currently to
our culture
to not just to america but to western
civilization i think this ideology is
cancerous it's evil and i think history
shows us where it's going to lead um
that ideology being so dominant i'm
afraid is also going to create this
reactionary
boogeyman that they keep pretending
exists because like you i think it's
been pretty inconsequential
nobody was showing up for kkk rallies a
few years ago yeah nobody
people rightfully pointed at those guys
and laughed and now
now this social justice left being
embraced by the mainstream is pushing
people there i don't think so you don't
think so
well no you you are correct but in a
different way
okay they are they
are this this group interesting robin
d'angelo says she's a racist
she's in her book she says she is she
does and she is a white woman
who is an avowed racist telling white
people to have a racial awakening to
make the world a better place
and that is the opening the door to
creating those
those groups no support and then when it
comes to the democratic party i'm like
well that aligns with history
you know well and look at what they're
pushing now tim they're so i don't know
if you saw at the smithsonian museums
they were pushing the stuff about
this culture and we're reading it off
and it's all and and i learned this
stuff
in school but now it's mainstream guys
and they're saying so
things like being on time
the concept of time working hard
strength perseverance um you know
survival skills reason logic individual
individualism math having a family
that these things are all functions of
whiteness how
racist is that towards anyone who's not
white yes
yes absolutely that is such i i
i have had this argument over and over
with these people
the these white sjws this is why i'm
saying they are the white supremacists
i had a guy actually tell me that the
concept of time was created by white
europeans
and then spread around the world and i'm
like buddy
east asian cultures were were further
advanced than european cultures like
way earlier you know the invention of
gunpowder there's a bunch of other
things that i don't need to you know
nitpick and stuff
but other cultures existed around the
around the the world
that had similar agriculture it wasn't
invented by you
but they believe it these people
literally believe that white people made
everything
and so that's why you know who else
believes that white supremacists yeah
well they are the one-to-one correlation
but so
you know call it teardrop theory call it
horseshoe theory you know some people
are creating a new circle thing i don't
i don't think any of these things
necessarily
encompass what's actually happening when
you so
that friend of mine i told you was
possessed yeah she made a post
where she said it's time for white
people like i'm paraphrasing
it was like white people need to wake up
to what it means to be white
and recognize their privilege and start
taking action and i
and i immediately was like you need to
call me and i said do you have any idea
what you just said dude so i've
like i'm like you you are literally
posting
you know she said something to me like
look i'm not talking to you
or marginalized communities i'm not
trying to disparage anybody i'm just
telling white people they need to wake
up and i was like
yes white racial collectivism
yeah we experienced that in this country
a long time ago yeah
and i when i when i when i try
explaining that california
just voted to repeal and the assembly
and the senate repealed the civil rights
civil rights law
yeah she didn't understand this
and i and so i ended up explaining to
her like
they they've just in in november it's
going to referendum and the democrats
are going to pass this and they're going
to take that away
so now you quite literally have the
question of who are the white
supremacists and where's the boogeyman
it's them they're getting rid of these
laws and they also like to say people
are reactionary they're reactionary
they're bringing us back in time they're
challenging free speech
bringing us back to an era when we
didn't have it they're challenging civil
rights bringing us back to the era where
it didn't exist
their ideology specifically says people
should judge others based on race and
identity sex and identity
and see the the ultimate ends of this
belief system
are the destruction of everything i mean
it's nihilistic it's a destruction of
individualism like you said free speech
everything that built this country
uh the destruction of equality but
here's the weird thing
there are the people who are in it who i
think
know what it is and they're just in it
for power
and totally this ideology is built
around worshiping power it is
it like i said this instead of being
built around class it's about power
when social justice warriors die they
say rest in power
they don't say rest in peace it tells
you what they value and they're all
saying a lot of that lately
have you noticed rest in power um but so
that's what they value and there are
those in it with bad intent and and they
know what it is and i have
little respect for those people
especially when they cloak themselves
in the word of god and try to sell it at
a christian church it disgusts me
but or when they're selling it in
schools it disgusts me in the elementary
schools
but they're also i think the vast
majority of these people
are in it with good intent i was in it
with good intent for 20 years
and they don't know that the ends are
the destruction of every
you know if you try to talk to most of
them like we're saying lydia they don't
have good historical context if you try
to even say
hey your your belief system is based in
marxism they're like whoa tinfoil hat
there carrie what's the
they don't even know what marxism means
they can't define it in their own words
they don't even know
you just gotta show them the teen vogue
article okay have you seen that
which one there's so many terrible ones
which one the one that said like mark
that praises marx oh my god i didn't see
that one
teen vogue wrote an article praising
karl marx that's amazing isn't it
yeah that people can walk around in this
country wearing you know you could you
could wave a soviet flag and people
would be like
huh like they killed tens or hundreds of
millions is like
the just the worst destruction of life
yeah
nightmarish i'm sorry i'm laughing
because you're right they don't know
and they just wear images and symbology
that they haven't given a lot of thought
to and they repeat
so a lot of people who push this they
just repeat these these
i call them the magic words of social
justice they just repeat them to
many of them are created to stop
conversation absolutely and they'll just
throw these things out and be like
oh yeah well that's your white fragility
boom and then like
okay what is that so you know what's
really fun
when i've literally used that against
them
and they break down they don't know what
to do they're like
well so it's really interesting however
most of them say fu
because they don't they don't play by
the rules i've been in arguments with
with you know some of these saws
they're typically white and i'll say
they'll say something you know well
let's just wait for jillian and i'll say
actually i'm not white so you need to
check your privilege
they'll snap because they don't care
about the rules they'll say f you
you're talking about as soon as you try
and challenge them and say no
the rules are gone because it was only
meant to hold you down
the rules never apply to them right well
it's the same thing listen
look at this bs so one of the things i
wrote in the piece that really
this really pisses me off is the way
that they're trying to complete
speech with violence so they have these
signs that say silence equals violence
your white silence is violence
or like your words are violence and the
reason they're doing that is they're
trying to take us to a place in society
where we think those things are the same
so that they can then justify actual
violence like the videos you took
they can say oh that's in self-defense
we beat that guy up with a brick over
the head because his words were violence
right and that's where they want to take
us which is a very evil place
words are violence and silence is
violence both what they're basically
saying is
say what we tell you to say or else
that's it and you know why that is
because they say
shut up and listen to black people shut
up and listen to women shut up and
listen to gay people and trans people
but then they say oh well not that woman
or that gay person or that black person
or not blaire white yeah not brandon
strzok not candace owens
the list goes on yeah yeah and i've been
and i'm still in a lot of social justice
groups on facebook so i like to see
you know what how they're updating their
um their magic words and
terms but they really say it like it's
abracadabra like white privilege boom
yeah but the funny great thing about
magic is if you don't believe in it
doesn't work on you and then they don't
know what to do
you're like i yeah i don't believe in
that uh
but they here's one quick thing i've
seen in these groups where they've
indoctrinated a bunch and like you said
it's mostly
white people they're indoctrinating and
a lot of them are well-intentioned white
women
and so they learn all the rules right
and you'll see some of them in these
groups who are saying
okay um and they'll post in good faith
like here's a video of candace so it's
like i just discovered this black woman
and she i don't understand what she's
saying but i'm willing to be quiet and
listen
because that's what they've learned to
say right i'm willing to be quiet and
listen
and then immediately in comes one of the
social justice high priestess or priests
of that group
and they're like here's why the rules
don't apply to that black person magic
words yeah yeah
and they roll over i've i experienced
this firsthand during occupy wall street
and my mom had a funny story so um it's
it's
you know most people have probably heard
me tell the story where i was there was
a white sjw
and some you know various different you
know minority group
people uh sjws and we were all arguing
the white guy called me white and told
me i need to listen and when i explained
to him that i was actually mixed
he went oh oh oh
now now i see what you're saying
this is this is why for me it's
particularly
i don't necessarily want to say
insidious but you know
problematic to say the least yes is that
as i've gotten said
it's not just about asian people but
particularly mixed asian people i called
schrodinger's people of color
okay but someone corrected me and said
no it's heisenberg's uncertainty people
of color
the the position of their marginalized
you know status
is dependent upon the observer you know
that's really true
that's hilarious thank you for that
phrase which one
well well this happened to a friend of
mine on facebook and i i
saved the comment thread because i just
wanted to have it forever
and it was where this white woman this
white sjw was going in hard on him and
calling all these names she didn't
realize that he was black
because his profile picture was very
clear and then at one point
he he kept asking her what do you mean
by marginalized people and she's like
i'm not here to do your emotional labor
for you and you know
it's not my job she was totally going
off and then at some point he's
she's like he says well i've looked it
up
and according to your definition i am a
marginalized person and literally her
next comment is like
i'm so sorry what can i do to help you
oh my gosh who who is that
radio host remember this yeah oh yeah i
remember this
she was like you wouldn't understand
from your position of privilege as a
white male and he goes
uh i'm i'm black i thought that your
producer would have filled you in
yes it's like i'm actually black yeah
and i have been blessed my whole life
it was remarkable when i told my friend
that repealing civil rights law was
terrifying to my family and she didn't
know anything about it
and said what how does this help your
family and i was like is that a joke
kidding like it was there there are uh
several genera there are several general
relation generations alive today
that lived through not having civil
rights
they have no historical context like you
were saying earlier so to them it's like
why does it matter let's get rid of it i
don't understand it i don't need it yeah
i don't need it so why should i care
privilege too and then you know there's
also this real arrogance
when i think in the belief system where
this tendency to look back at history
and judge things
through the current lens and for people
to believe that they're so much
smarter and they're more morally upright
than everyone else who's ever walked the
earth
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you